I want greatness for you and I'm willing
to bet that everyone in your life that
loves you wants the same thing they want
to see you make your dreams come true
they hunger for it to see you win the
way that you hunger for it yourself
but what they know that you may not yet
be willing to accept is that is
rabindranath tagore said you can't cross
the sea merely by standing and staring
at the water if you're gonna make those
things come true in your life if you're
going to make that Vision that you have
a reality you've ultimately got to go
out into the cold and unforgiving water
you've got to be willing to face the
swells you've got to be willing to face
the most terrifying thing of all the
unknown it isn't that the sea is
dangerous that scares people it's that
you can't see what's beneath the surface
and that is going to be the challenge
that you're going to have to face that
is going to have to be the fear that you
stare directly into the eye is the truth
is you don't know what you're capable of
the truth is you don't know if you're
going to succeed the absolute truth is
you may fail you may get swallowed by
the darkness but at the end of the day
that's going to be your choice because
whether or not you fail does not mean
you have to be consumed by that failure
you can get back up and keep going but
that is a choice you have to make that's
the fortitude you have to develop within
and it is a development process it is
something that you do you choose to be
stronger than the sea you choose to be
stronger than the unknown and you choose
to be brave enough to go out despite the
unknown and try to conquer something to
try to build something in your life to
do the things that other people think
cannot be done it is in facing that fear
that you win the battle understand
finding the island making it to the new
world that's not the point the point is
setting out the point is being willing
to get an adini and to go off into the
sea the point is being willing to face
the challenge
if you can do that regardless of what
comes you've already won because you've
proven something to yourself
that you're willing to try hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I quit on
my business partner I was making 300
bucks a month and I didn't have the
motivation to keep going and the thing
that got me through was studying the
stories of entrepreneurs who've had
massive success and I hope that in
sharing these stories with you you find
a motivation to keep going and if I'm
being honest I still need to source for
myself today too so today let's learn
from some of the best and pick up how to
keep going and believe in yourself enjoy
rule number two is never doubt yourself
with Dean graziosi I want my children to
be richer smarter better looking happier
joyful I want them to be thousand times
better than me I want them to go oh Dean
was 1.0 his kids are 4.0 his
grandchildren are 6.0 oh my God by the
time we get to my great grandchild I
want them to make fun of what a pathetic
weakling loser I was like that's what I
hope right if we want that for them so
much and if you're not a parent it's
okay you'll like you you could still
feel those same emotions you can
understand what we're talking about here
if we want them for want that for them
then why the hell don't we deserve it
for us
right like how do we Pierce This Heart
how do we Pierce this self-doubt how do
we pierce the thinking that we have that
God is here our best thinking got us
right here it makes another level of
thinking another level of passion
another level of feeling uncomfortable
and being disturbed with where you are
to move it's the spaceship it takes all
the energy to get it like a hundred feet
off the ground once it's out of the
atmosphere it hits a little button and
goes fast but it takes all that energy
get off the ground so my goal in some of
my trainings each month is to give you
that burst of energy to get done today
and go screw it I'm freaking doing this
like nothing is going to stop me and I
know so many of you are massively
successful this isn't about oh you're
pathetic and this it's about where you
are you know there's another level
that's all it is and it doesn't mean
it's never enough listen God didn't put
us on this Earth to settle I don't think
I think at the end of our life if we
have the opportunity to talk to our
maker he's not going to say I'm so glad
you found your groove at 24 years old
and kind of settled for another 70 years
like that's not what he wants that's not
what we're designed for I always say
Dale Carnegie's quote my favorite one by
him he said the human the biggest plight
of the human race
is knowing you have more potential
and you're not using it
like you say that you're like yeah yes
right so how do we trick ourselves into
knowing that we deserve this we need we
deserve to take uncomfortable action to
fail forward and to figure it out
because if you think about that
how are we with I know this is far away
from business and stuff but how are we
with kind of our inner peace like making
amends with ourselves we help our kids
solve problems we help our kids not have
regrets we help our kids not have
enemies or let go of pain like we we I
maybe I'm wrong but like we wherever we
are we want what's best for them we know
you're studying personal growth you're
studying letting go you're studying
focusing on Solutions you're doing all
this well simultaneously
internally you might be fighting with
yourself and still have that person that
you need to forgive or forgive yourself
for the mistakes in the past or forgive
yourself for procrastinating or forgive
yourself to that you were scared up to
this point or forgive yourself that you
screwed up the relationship it was you
we want our kids to forgive themselves
we want them to forgive others we want
them to work on being grateful and
having gratitude and simultaneously we
wake up sometimes and our guts are
spinning while we're helping someone
else is it true let me know in the chat
if anything I'm saying here today is
resonating right
so if that's the case why are we waiting
to fix this in the Next Generation
you got a lot of years left on this
Earth let's fix it with us remember like
just think this this is what I try to do
all the time is If I Stay this way my
kids are going to be that way I
literally punish myself that way because
if I stay this way they're gonna be this
way there's there's nothing I can do to
change it right
another thing I wrote down is like who
are we when no one's watching like we
think we can put this facade on in front
of our children
right it could be children it could be
spouse it could be partner it could be
friends but we get to put this face on
in front of other people right but then
who are we when no one's around
because I still believe our kids become
who we are when no one's around
I think kids are the biggest like
lie detector [ __ ] detector excuse my
language like they just feel who you are
and they become it okay who in here has
ever had something that you do that
you're like oh this is mine or it's
adult or it's kind of quirky I never
want my kids to see this one thing I've
done and then if you've had kids they're
a certain age and they do that exact
thing that you think you protected them
from it their whole entire life I see a
laughing James like like where did that
come from I didn't teach you that it's
like it's intuitive so who are we when
no one's watching
is even important right and that leads
to our values doesn't it right what we
do when people aren't watching is just
that's our character we could say our
characters one thing we can pretend our
values are one thing when no one's
watching the things you do that's who
you are but you know what the most
congruent thing in the history of the
world is
is being the same human when no one's
watching and when everyone's watching
that's one of the things I strive for
more than anything rule number three
keep going with Mel Robbins when life
suddenly changes
and you feel like you have lost control
and you start to feel stuck and
Powerless how do you take control when
you don't know where your life or the
world or this moment is going
and here's the number one thing I want
you to know you don't need to know where
this moment or where the world is going
you just need to know where you are
going next and one of the things that
has happened uh certainly in the
pandemic but it always happens when
there's any kind of Reckoning in your
life
is that when you have something suddenly
happen and your life is fundamentally
changed whether it's a death or somebody
says I don't love you anymore or you're
fired or you find yourself uh with a
scary Health diagnosis there is a line
in the sand there is a life before
that happened and then a life after that
moment happened and that line in the
sand that Reckoning that happens and it
happens for all of us whether it's
happening for you right now or it has
happened in the past I'm telling you
there is a gift inside of this even the
darkest moments because every single
Sudden Change in your life that makes
you feel like you've lost control and
you no longer know where you're going
it's like hitting the giant pause button
and if you lean into the moment
there is a chance for tremendous wisdom
and growth there are things that you can
do right now in order to take control of
where you're going of what you're
thinking about and you can start to take
this moment of change and you can use it
to be able to take and make an
intentional pivot in the direction that
is meant for you next and one of the
things I want to say about this moment
is look if you're losing loved ones you
are terrified this has made you lose
your job you feel like you're in that
moment where everything you know you're
falling off a cliff you're trying to
pack a parachute you're grieving and so
you got to give yourself space to grieve
the losses that you're feeling and when
you get a little bit of distance from
The Grieving and the ways of grief and
fear that you're feeling start to space
out they don't ever leave you but over
time those waves of holy cow and I don't
want this and I can't handle this and
why is this happening to me
time will start to lessen those waves
you will gather your feet underneath you
again and you will absolutely
be stronger and be a better version of
yourself based on this incredible
challenge that you're facing and I can
say that even though you may be facing
in a tough time because if you think
about your life you faced extraordinary
challenges and there hasn't been a
single one that hasn't made you a better
and stronger version of yourself and
this moment will be no different so I
want you to understand that when you get
out of the cycle of grief this is an
enormous Reckoning an enormous
opportunity for you to hit the pause
button and for you to start to ask
yourself the question what do I want my
life to look like
because I think too many of us are
sitting here going I can't wait for my
life to get back to normal I can't wait
for this to end I can't wait to things
to go back to normal and in any moment
of Reckoning what happens is there's
actually parts of your old life
that you don't want to go back to
and there is a tremendous amount that
you're learning in this moment that you
need to pause and take in and say okay
based on what I've just learned based on
my old life when I look ahead to my new
life what is it that I want my new life
to look like this next chapter I can
turn to a blank page I can take all this
wisdom all this resilience all this
strength and I can write something new
that's what I want you to know you don't
need to know where the world or where
everything is headed you just need to
know where you're gonna head next
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four Hustle Hard with
Ed mylett I want to get started today by
asking you a couple things number one
are you clear on what you really want
like with all the information being
thrown at you I want you to think about
this for a minute right because
complexity is the enemy of execution
so the more stuff that gets thrown at
you if you're not completely clear on
exactly what it is you want okay you're
never going to get it and we're going to
talk about getting clear on those things
today but somehow inside of you finding
the version of you that's capable of
doing those things is the most important
thing so what I want to have happen
today I hope is this experience that we
talk about happiness but we also talk
about fulfillment I don't want you to
make all your financial goals happen and
find yourself unfulfilled I know more
people with money that aren't fulfilled
than I do people without money if you
can't find a way to be happy in this
moment in this time right now I promise
you when you arrive at wealth you are
going to bring you with you and it will
only magnify the things you don't like
about yourself when you get a bunch of
money I learned that firsthand but I
think it's important that you not always
just see the after that you also see the
before because as an entrepreneur you're
all entrepreneurs now right you're going
to have false start after false start
you're going to get it going and then
it's going to go backwards you're going
to make progress it's going to go
backwards you're going to think you have
a deal and then you don't you're going
to make money on three Deals and then
you won't it's going to get going and go
backwards it happens as an entrepreneur
over and over and over again so I tell
you when I tell you that I have respect
for you that I admire what you're trying
to do with your life I mean that
sincerely I know what it's like to want
to change your life's conditions I know
what it's like to want to win for your
family and I know what it's like to not
be totally sure you're going to do it so
when I tell you I understand the journey
and I admire and respect you
I may I may admire and respect you even
at a level most people don't
I know what it's like to fail
and then once I started to turn it
around I wanted to win so bad I was
going to fake it till I made it I tell
you that to start out today it's a long
way of telling you I relate to where you
are to some extent some of you too cool
you're like well I'm not liking that
kind of a condition yes you are you're
broke
you're broke and until you admit where
you are and Define where you are and
quit playing it cool and try to fool
everybody about where you are you're
going to keep losing
let me be real with you now that I've
been funny with you now we're going to
get real stop bullshiting everybody
you're not fooling anybody you talk to a
real wealthy man I know what you really
got going on and by the way your Uncle
Larry the lawyer making 350 Grand a year
that ain't money
that's not money
if you're not at least at multiple seven
figures in this world you are still
broke trust me my brother-in-law makes
280 thousand dollars he lives in Chino
Hills he can't even afford to buy a damn
house right now where he lives because
he can't save now if he had these
strategies he probably could do it right
but do not fool yourself that you got it
going or you need to be in a big damn
hurry
time is running out on you there's 86
400 seconds in a day
the separator between me and you and
people that win and lose is what we do
with those seconds and you're too slow
you're too cool you're too casual you
think too much you need to get in a
hurry the separator in this room you're
all learning the same things the
separator is going to be who takes
massive action quickly you all learn the
same things I know all you know
lots of guys know what I know why aren't
they wealthy why don't they have a 40
million dollar jet why don't they live
Oceanfront Laguna Beach why don't they
have the most unbelievable homes in the
world in Coeur d'Alene Idaho why don't
they retire their parents why don't when
their daughter breaks their nose they go
to an urgent care if some doofus snaps
it back I go to a 25 000 surgeon write a
check and don't think about it for my
kids
and I'm the guy driving the Chrysler
LeBaron man I'm the guy whose water was
turned off
so listen to me look at my hands you
stop playing around
I'm looking around this room not all of
you are 19 years old time's running out
on you well number five is follow your
dreams with Lewis Howes I started to
steal every single day in order to gain
friends there are two kids in the
neighborhood who said hey do you want to
join our club
and I said yes because I don't have any
friends so what's it going to take they
said well there's one of two options you
could one answer a question to see if
you can join you're smart enough to join
the club or two pay money and I didn't
have any money and I'm eight years old
I said okay what are the questions and
there were two questions that they asked
I didn't know the answer to either one
of these and so they said sorry you
can't join the club unless you pay us
money so I walk home
with my head down and asked my mom hey
mom can I have some money it was five
dollars at the time which was a lot for
me eight years old I said can I have
five dollars and I go back to this their
house
and I'm in the club for a day and I give
them the money and I remember feeling so
you know shameful and just like a loser
because I literally had to pay money to
have two neighborhood boys be friends
with me and add me in their Club but I
was doing it only for myself
it was to prove others wrong it was to
prove the kids that picked me last on
the dodgeball court in in fourth grade
that I'm going to prove you wrong I'm
going to be something of myself I'm
going to be better than you it was to
prove the kids that I had to pay five
dollars to join their Club so I could
have friends that I'm going to prove you
wrong about me it was always to prove
someone wrong I wanted to achieve my
dreams so that I could be right they
could be wrong I started to achieve all
my dreams every dream that I had when I
realized the power of dreams they all
started to come true everything I set
myself out to do it happens and I
remembered feeling so
ungrateful and unfulfilled within
minutes after I achieved all these
dreams all state in multiple Sports in
high school All-American and two sports
playing professional sports I was like a
dream when I was on my sister's couch to
make a thousand dollars and I did that
and I was ungrateful then it was five
thousand dollars I did that and I was
ungrateful then it was 20 000 a month a
hundred thousand I need to make my first
million it was never good enough I was
always ungrateful right why am I so
upset and so unfulfilled when I'm
achieving my dreams and it wasn't until
I started to say you know what I got
perspective it's not whether or not I
achieved the dream it's what I learn and
who I become in the pursuit of the
church now yes I want to achieve all my
goals and all my dreams
but some of them haven't happened
and I look back and I say you know what
at least the last 10 years or five years
or two years of this journey of going
after this dream look at the
relationships I've made look at the
lessons I've learned look at how much
I've grown it's about how can I win and
also make everyone else around me win in
whatever that looks like for them how
could I create that so follow your
dreams they matter because you matter
I'm rule number six the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is use
negativity to grow with Marie forleo so
curious have you ever had someone not
believe in you or they said something
really horrible about your work where it
felt like a punch in the gut and just
left you thinking oh my God how could
someone be that mean I have so let me
tell you what it did for me and more
importantly what it could do for you so
back in 2009 my program b-school was
getting ready to be brought into the
world and I was trying to do everything
I could to make it a success I was
trying to network find promotional
Partners basically get the word out all
over so I went to this business
conference in Washington DC and I was so
excited to be there I had my little
conference badge around my neck I had my
big conference binder under my arm
everything was going good so I'm on the
escalator heading to go up to one of the
main sessions and there was this guy in
front of me and he was part of the
conference too so of course as you do at
conferences he turned around and he
asked me he's like oh so what do you do
this was the perfect opportunity I was
so excited I started telling him about
b-school I said oh I'm launching this
incredible online business program for
women entrepreneurs and so he says oh
that's cute is that a hobby
do you actually make money doing that or
do you have a rich husband who's
bankrolling you for one of the very few
times in my life I was absolutely
speechless I felt like I just got gonged
by the ultimate business d-bag I was
thinking to myself I cannot believe
a-holes like this still exist and thank
God it was a short little escalator ride
because I wanted to throw him over that
freaking escalator I got myself together
I mustered out something about that I
had been successfully supporting myself
in business for the last nine years and
then I did whatever I could to get away
from that turd muncher as fast as
humanly possible now here's my point
while that guy was a total ignorado for
what he said to me I actually thank him
for not believing in me I thank him for
underestimating me I thank him for being
a totally ignorant chauvinistic piece of
poop you know why because he actually
fueled me to make b-school even more of
a success I was already committed to it
but after that interaction and nothing
was going to stop me now I know that not
everybody is wired in the exact same way
but for me when I want something really
bad and someone basically says you can't
do that it just gets me totally fired up
and motivated to prove them wrong and
yes I know in a certain spiritual
framework we don't want to be reactive
to life but what I'm saying is this is
that every single thing that happens to
you including what I now call escalator
moments are fuel for growth and
sometimes even more so than the
encouraging moments
all commitments require investments in
time and money all commitments you
cannot make a commitment without time
and money being invested time and money
has to be invested you have to invest
time and money if it's not on your
schedule you're not committed if you
don't have money back by that time on
your calendar if it's not costing you
money or you don't have money deposited
right there you are not committed
where you have your money is where your
personal spiritual emotional physical
commitments go whatever your money is is
who you are most committed to
Wells Fargo Bank of America Citibank
you guys many of you got more money at
Wells Fargo than you have invested in
your own advertising the market
because you guys are committed to the
live
the Big Marketing scam of the universe
save your money
save your money
what you should do is you should get a
good job first of all you should
avoid borrowing money
unless it's for something that we think
is good for you
right
so first of all you should not borrow
money unless
it's one of our credit cards
where we give you points
and one day you too will be able to stay
at a Holiday Inn for free
where by the way the buffets at the
kitchen are free you can eat all you
want not to mention that you're already
overweight but you could go there and
eat all you want for as long as you want
butter
if you just borrow enough money on this
card
to buy enough stuff you don't need
to pay us back one day if you can
right and then during the week when
you're not borrowing money from us what
you should do is spend your time getting
money to pay for the book that belt that
you bought and put on your credit card
that you can't write off others so this
is what Americans are doing people all
around the world spend 40 hours a week
running around hustling
yeah they get hundred dollars what do
they do now they run over here to the
bank drop off the hundred bucks then
they run back out do another 40 weeks
pick up a thousand dollars man I had a
great week didn't I bang and then they
run over here and drop it off at the
bank these are the good Americans
the bad Americans go pick up a thousand
bucks and go to the club and blow it
the good Americans run run around
collecting a thousand dollars five
thousand dollars ten thousand dollars
Hustlers Hustlers man hard workers they
they get sophisticated ugh I'm gonna put
a little money in the bank over here
over here at Wells Fargo I'm gonna have
a little over here at Citibank I'ma
spread this sh around
I want to be a slave to many not a slave
to a few
I'm gonna give a little to Bank of
America I'm gonna give a little bit to
City Bank I'm gonna give a little bit to
the Wells Fargo I'm gonna give a little
bit to Fidelity and Merrill Lynch I'm
going to give a little bit to my IRA and
my 401k I'm gonna bust my ass I'm gonna
spend 40 years killing myself to make
sure all these institutions
have my money
where they pay me nothing
for the sake of security
right and then you guys look up one day
you're like where's my money at it's in
all these accounts by the way what do
those people do with your money when
they get it
they call me up
hey Mr Cardone
we got another dummy
guy spent goddamn he must have spent 160
hours put together a little Bank
extremely disciplined dumbass
and and he saved hundred thousand
dollars with us and we'd like to know Mr
Cardone if you would like to borrow that
money
his money
yeah I sure would because we know Mr
Cardone that you'll put that money to
work
okay this guy that gave it to us all he
wants to do is work
I'm like yes send me that money bro send
me that money okay and they by the way
they're not done calling me they're
going to call nine other people
they're going to take his 100 Grand and
they're going to say they're gonna
they're gonna lend it out nine hundred
thousand dollars of it and this is the
banking system
and that is debt by the way
that U.S dollar
okay they're basically multiplying money
if the bank doesn't keep it why do you
spend all your time giving it to them
to keep for you the reality is that
those who can delay eating the
marshmallow the longest do the best
because you're right delaying
gratification is an absolute superpower
now one of the most extraordinary
experiments was done at Stanford
University it's called the marshmallow
experiment there's a whole book written
on this utterly fascinating they
followed the participants in the study
for like 25 years absolutely incredible
they bring these kids into a room they
give them a marshmallow and they say Hey
you can eat the marshmallow now if you
want but if you wait until I come back
then I'll give you two marshmallows so
it's basically double your money it's
not going to be that long now what the
kid doesn't know is that the researcher
isn't coming back and they just want to
see how long the kid is going to wait
until they eat it they do eventually
come back but they leave them really to
struggle for quite some time and
what they found was the kids that could
come up with games where they're singing
to themselves not looking at the
marshmallow whatever the kids that were
able to delay the gratification the
longest ended up doing the best they got
the best grades they got the highest
paying jobs they had the most successful
relationships now the reason that that
works is in any one moment if you're
just operating around optimizing for
momentary mind States brain States
neurochemical states then you're always
going to be in short-term thinking
you're always going to get short-term
results if however you have this goal
that excites you and is Honorable
and you're able to push through all the
boring stuff and all of that then what
you get is a set of skills that allow
you to do things other people can't do
and as we establish in the last question
if you can do things other people can't
do that is by its very nature success
and you will be rewarded in a way that
other people will not be rewarded
because they can't do the things you do
and as long as the things you do are
valued by Society then you are always
going to do very well
but that ultimately is the key you have
to be able to delay gratification now
for me understanding that that was the
nature of things that if I can delay my
momentary wishes for something longer
term then I could get these very
different results that separated me from
other people and because I'm excited
about what I'm pursuing I use that
excitement as my trick to stay focused
when things get boring and I've said
many times that boredom kills more
entrepreneurs than failure so everyone
will tell you that fear of failures what
stops people and that is a huge deal but
honestly like I think it's the fact that
people don't want the outcome badly
enough to fight through all the boring
painful stuff that you have to go
through to get to the other side to
ultimately be successful so
make sure that you are hyped up on your
goal if you're not then you're not going
to be willing to go through all the
difficult things why is identity so
important for us to shape a positive
powerful identity well first of all so I
wouldn't understand what I mean by
identity is we all have a way of
identifying ourselves we have a way of
labeling ourselves so most of us came up
with our labels based on how we behaved
but really smart people can do stupid
things really nice people can be mean
mean people can be nice and so if you
judge yourself too soon and most
people's identity their labels for
themselves who they think they are has
been based on their past and often many
years ago and so they don't update it so
that the metaphor I give for identities
like
it's your comfort zone it's not your
goals so if you like if you took a
temperature in the room and said 68
degrees is my comfort zone physically
emotionally financially I want more in
my relationship I want more physically
energy wise I want more financially in
my career but this is what I'm used to
and so what happens people stay in their
comfort zone for the most part and then
let's say something happens and you dip
you're a 68 degree or that's your
mentality and you drop down to 62 61 60
somewhere around 60 or 59 the heaters
kick on and go whoa whoa whoa
you're 68 degree what the hell are you
doing we've all experienced that all of
a sudden you go I'm not going to live
like this anymore I'm not going to be in
this relationship I'm not going to be
fat like this how boom and you get this
drive and you start to change but what
most people don't understand
is it happens on the upper end too
meaning let's say you got momentum you
start crushing you start doing even
better than you think you go from 68 to
70 88 you're 98 Degrees financially
emotionally spiritually whatever the
metaphor is and then what happens you're
going to say hey you're bringing us who
the hell do you think you are you're not
a 98 degree here
all right get back to 68 and if nothing
else the heaters stop you lose your
drive and that'll drift you back and not
enough the air condition can kick on you
start to kind of sabotage yourself till
you get back to your comfort zone so
unless you expand your identity change
is temperance like when someone says to
me I stopped smoking it's been eight
days and I say why are you counting
so you can tell people how long you
lasted this time
and if I went to somebody and and I said
to you hey you know Louis you want a
cigarette you're not going to say what
brand is it you know no okay I'm not a
smoker notice how people I'm not one of
those that's not my identity
identity is the strongest force in the
human personality if you look Lance
Armstrong was a mixed identity now in
the culture
this is a guy that had to win and found
a way to win it so when he was told he
had cancer in his lungs and his brain
and in his testicles and he rides a bike
and he's gonna die his answer was no I'm
a champion I find the way I will find
the answer and he did now unfortunately
he bent the rules around the sport and
it kind of ruined his reputation
obviously but that mentality his
identity is why he survived other people
told they have cancer and they're like
it's over they give up they start
arranging their Affairs and so that
psychological difference is the number
one thing I work with people on Because
unless you expand your identity you're
gonna basically keep where you are you
might improve a little or not you might
go up and down a bit but you're going to
stay within a realm if you're gonna have
an explosive breakthrough to another
level physically mentally financially
spiritually then we got to not only give
you the tools we got to shift that
internal sense of who you really are and
have you find that you are more than
anything that's ever happened to you
that you can handle whatever shows up
even if it's incredibly scary or
uncomfortable I was born in Belarus in
the former Soviet Union I came to the
U.S when I was three we lived a very
humble beginning as you can imagine the
economy wasn't super great we didn't
speak English we had a hundred bucks I
lived with seven family members in a
studio apartment in Queens so it was
super humble as you and you know
obviously my parents are very much my
heroes uh one because my mom is the
greatest parent of all time and two
because my dad worked his face off and
even though I slept under the same roof
literally every day of my life with my
dad in the first 14 years of my life I
literally never saw him because he left
at 7 A.M or 6 a.m and he came home at 10
p.m and he worked seven days a week how
many people here are immigrants or
children of immigrants raise your hands
awesome so this group that just raised
their hands they know that immigrants in
America have absolutely figured out one
of the core Secrets which is you know
work your face off and don't buy dumb
foreign
and so that's kind of what my family did
for seven or eight years you know we my
dad wasn't making that much money but a
funny thing happens when you buy nothing
but food at the lowest possible price
and uh save save save save save save and
very quickly only six years after Coming
To America with 100 bucks my dad was
able to buy a small liquor store in New
Jersey we moved to New Jersey that is
where my entrepreneurial career began uh
when I was six I had a five Lemonade
Stand franchise
I uh manipulated my friends into
standing behind the lemonade all day and
that is when I became obsessed with
attention and this is really interesting
as you can see up here I day trade
attention culture and build businesses
at six years old
I would spend my summer days literally
walking up and down the streets of New
Jersey
sitting down on the curb watching cars
drive by so that I could figure out
which tree or post was better for me to
put a sign that said lemonade a quarter
that is DNA that's like somebody singing
That's like somebody throwing a pitch
really like that is just pure DNA I
didn't read a Seth Godin book or go to
Harvard Business School to figure out
that attention was the number one asset
the one thing that combines every person
here from the cameramen back there who
are producing to the industry that is in
this room to me to Mickey to anybody
else that sneaked in the one thing that
fundamentally connects all of us is
before you tell me how great your
product and services you need my
attention so that I listen I am obsessed
with attention I am obsessed with this
device because it has the attention I am
unemotional if it's ruining the kids and
they don't know how to engage or that
you were sad that people go out to
dinner and don't talk to each other
technology does not care about your
feelings
and so I as a human may have some
opinions about Parenthood and and
society and privacy as a human
but as a businessman I am unemotional
and not romantic all I do is follow
where the attention is and I figure out
how to storytell in there to create the
action that I desire one of the things
that will help you to do the work to
create the things that you want in your
life
is it will help you if you train your
mind
to start spotting evidence as you're
doing the work as you're going through
your day it will help you if you train
your mind to start scanning the world
and spotting evidence that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because if you
get into a negative mindset if you start
thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother I'm never going to meet
anybody it's nothing but losers out
there look at all these idiots on hinge
why the hell should I keep doing this if
you allow your mind to start to rest in
a pessimistic negative protective scared
and doubtful stance your mind will
continue to show you reasons why there's
nobody on hinged worth talking to your
mind will continue to show you all the
reasons why you will never make it in
business your mind will continue to show
you all the reasons why you're never
going to lose that weight and be able to
tuck in your shirt as my friend Corinne
Crabtree always talks about that
transformational moment and when your
mind goes negative your mind starts to
scan the world and will show you more
reasons to stop and the power of
training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple the power is that
your mind will start to show you reasons
to keep going your mind will help you
take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered
just like you woke up today on a Tuesday
and it was February 22nd 2022 and those
numbers are lining up and that makes you
in your heart and soul go whoa something
cool could happen today like that [ __ ]
only happens like once in my lifetime
those numbers are going to line up like
that today is a really cool date let's
go do something with this you could
create that kind of attitude every
single freaking day of your life you
could if you train your mind and if you
start taking action and training your
mind is the key piece that we're going
to talk about so for those of you that
have read the high five habit one of the
things that I talk about a lot is every
single day find a naturally occurring
heart-shaped object in the world it
could be a stone it could be a leaf it
could be a cloud it could be a shape in
your coffee hey Chris if we've got
anything around here that looks like a
heart hand it to me and the reason why I
love telling you to start playing a game
with yourself well you start your day
going mind brain show me some heart oh
what is this come here dog treat oh my
God it's a dog treat look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a harp
there we go check that out if you say
brain mind show me a heart today guess
what's going to happen that damn dog
biscuit it's gonna show it's gonna
you're gonna be like there's a heart
you're gonna look out at the sky and
you're gonna see a heart shape oh right
there in the mountains there's a heart
shape in the mountains in southern
Vermont you're going to see it in the
clouds what you're doing when you tell
your mind what's important to you is
you're telling your mind and the filter
in your brain to change in real time and
allow into your consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by God those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me Mel Robbins on social media you will
see every day I am reposting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying this I
don't want to see all the reasons why
I'm unhappy I don't want to see
everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good uh marriage or relationship
and I don't want to see that and and
have my mind process it as evidence that
it's never going to happen for me I want
my mind to reprogram itself and see
other people's businesses and see other
people getting healthy and see other
people in relationships and I want my
mind to say yeah if they can do it I can
do it that's evidence if that person can
get healthy so can I if that person can
find somebody unhinged so can I if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can I other people can become evidence
that you can have it too right now your
mind is so [ __ ] up from your past that
when you see what other people have and
you don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
going to win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 2 22 22 and your brain saw that
was like whoa this is a once in a
lifetime day everybody
you're never going to have another day
that lines up like this ever
what are you gonna do with this day your
mind already interpreted this as wow
something cool could happen
and if you tell yourself something
amazing is going to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it I swear to God
something will something will if you
want to see the good all around you you
got to tell your mind you want to see
the good and this just isn't a bunch of
horsesh everybody this isn't toxic
positivity there is a filter in your
brain called the reticular activating
system
the reticular activating system I call
it the RAS I like to think about it like
a giant hair net on your head and this
Ras sits over your brain I'm probably
getting this wrong I'm not a
neuroscientist I could give about
getting it right I just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a PhD
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's
what I'm here for in your life I'm here
to translate this stuff into simple
believable and actionable things that
you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and
apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to help you change from
the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is
you have a whole system in your body
that you can train and change and one of
those things that you can train and
change that is impacted by that real
that word you're hearing a lot of
neuroplasticity that just means that
things are able to twist and bend and
change and you're able to learn new
things for as long as you're alive as
long as you're breathing everybody you
got a chance to change the way that you
think as long as you are breathing you
got a chance to change from the inside
out how you experience your life as long
as you are still here watching me people
you got a chance to create a new
experience in your life and one of the
things that helps a lot is understanding
that right now all of the bullsh from
your past has jammed the filter in your
mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see hearts remember this dog
treat hearts look at that there's a
heart right there if you're trying to
reach the decision maker at a retail
organization that guy or gal is also the
same person that I want to reach to sell
a bottle of wine or a book to and that
space in his and her Facebook feed is
only one space
so that is supply and demand I used to
buy that space four years ago for a
dollar for every thousand Impressions
now it's seven the longer you think this
world doesn't exist and you
fear-mongerate the longer you don't put
money in the longer I can extract all
the value I've lived this game I'm not a
hero because I took it from 3 to 50
million 60 million my dad's business I
actually am a schmuck I should have
spent more on Google
I had it figured out every time you
typed in Cabernet Merlot Silver Oak
Camus Napa Bordeaux I was showing up
first because nobody realized it was
good real estate and it was only costing
me five or ten cents a click and I was
making between seven and eighty dollars
in profit for something that was costing
me three dollars to get you through the
funnel on the average of 60 people
coming and one converting I was stupid
I'm being serious with you I stand here
and have passion about LinkedIn and
Facebook marketing in a B2B environment
today out of regret for what I did from
2002 to 2005 because I should have spent
more it was basic math but I just didn't
understand
because I was young in my career and it
just I don't even know how to explain it
to you when it's too good to be true
it's too good to be true right I'm an
immigrant I was cynical I just didn't
plus I also thought it was important to
do direct mail and local commercials and
magazine I was doing it all but in
hindsight it was the great mistake of my
career
the great mistake of my career was not
spending more money on Google and I
promise you the great mistake of your
accelerated growth for the 80 that just
raised their hand is not taking
advertising on LinkedIn and Facebook
seriously because you don't think your
person is on it I've heard every guys
I've been doing this for 10 years I know
what your excuse is going to be I can't
wait to the Q a I'm going to stand here
and but Gary my my target person is a 63
year old man he's not on it [ __ ]
of course he's on it who do you think is
spreading all the Democratic and
Republican propaganda on Facebook let's
play a game and let's call this game
what would Tom do
now I want you to ask do you think that
Tom is going to stay in a bad job for
long
no
that's the I'll skip to the last page
and Tom has a bad job uh skip to the
last page tom leaves the job now Tom is
going to be very thoughtful because I
completely understand that this is
largely about yo I have to pay bills hey
Tom nice for you you don't have kids and
you've already been successful so that's
not really helpful for me
now I will say that
joy and fulfillment are the punchline of
life not money not success not adoration
so you are losing losing losing if
you're staying in a job that makes you
unhappy I promise if you have kids and
that's the thing that's really making
this difficult you are bringing that
unhappiness home and so we have a moral
obligation to break that to make sure
that we are pursuing things that are
joyful so that we can show our kids hey
this is how it's done now you're not
stuck at a job there's something that's
making you feel stuck at the job I'm
going to assume for now that it's money
keeping a roof over your loved one's
heads that that to me seems like the
scariest so okay assuming that it's that
remember there are always two levers
lever number one make more money lever
number two need less money okay you can
pull on either lever you want now if you
say up Tom I can't need less money just
we're all we've already cut it all to
the quick you know my kids just need a
certain amount and just is what it is
okay amazing so now we're gonna make
more money awesome how do we go about
doing that first of all let's identify
what we hate about our job because there
might be are there other roles within
that company if it's just the job but
not the company is there somewhere that
we could move in which case we go ask
hey I want this job which pays more
money what would I need to do what skill
set would I need to have what expertise
would I need to demonstrate in order to
get there
and then go do that thing
if it's the company and we just the
company's toxic we can't be there
anymore then I will ask how many resumes
have you sent out in the last 48 hours
if the answer isn't 250 then we've got
some work to do
now let's assume that the answer is 250.
then we have to figure out why aren't we
getting a response do we not have a
skill set that's marketable is our
resume terrible are we not going out to
the right places have we not framed
ourself well
could be any one of those things but we
have to be honest and real and figure
out what we need to do to get out of
this situation but we certainly don't
just accept defeat and go wow this sucks
this is my whole life
nights and weekends is also going to
come to our
help our Aid here so nights and weekends
if you know whoa I just don't have the
skill set that I need to go find another
job then we're going to start building
that skill set maybe the skill set is
interviewing getting good at
interviewing and then we're going to get
good at that but we are going to find a
way out of our situation and we are
going to find a way out of our situation
quickly so do not accept defeat hold
yourself accountable to the truth to
what you need to do to get out of that
situation and then get out
because as you said our time is truly
limited we live in a world that
reinforces a scarcity mentality and that
mentality keeps us an energy of lack it
keeps us from attracting the career path
that we want the abundance that we want
and allowing us to really live our
purpose
there are six common blocks to abundance
and we all experience them in different
ways the first block is a lack mentality
and when we have a belief system around
lack we create more lack in our life we
all have stories from our childhood how
our parents experienced abundance or how
they didn't and those stories start to
create a inner dialogue that gets us
into a vibration of feeling like we
don't have enough and if we feel like we
don't have enough we do a lot of work to
try to prove to the world that we are
enough the second block is the belief
system that there's not enough to go
around we often overwork to try to get
it all we're constantly trying to get
get because we don't believe that there
is enough it makes us feel like we have
to work so hard to get what we want and
that effort and that anxiety is really
really blocking the natural order which
is the flow of abundance
the third block is the block of
comparison we literally just turn on our
social media and we're immediately into
compare compare compare and comparing
blocks or attracting power because it
focuses us on what we don't have rather
than feeling good and feeling faith
the fourth block is the need to win in
the place of having fun because when
we're so focused on winning we lose
track of what it feels like to enjoy the
process and that winning can really get
in our way of allowing
the fifth block is the fear of rejection
When We Fear rejection we don't take
action and in effect we create more lack
in our life because we're not actually
trying we're not actually putting out
our desires we're not actually taking
that leap towards what we want but it's
important to understand that rejection
can be protection when we have some form
of rejection show up in our life it's
the universe guiding us to something
better
and the final block is the fear of
judgment
you may be so terrified of being judged
that you don't take that action you
don't show up for your dreams you don't
even contemplate a world where you could
do the thing that you've been dreaming
of you're so afraid of judgment because
you think that other people won't
support you but what's really important
to recognize is that if you're afraid of
what other people think and how they
won't support you it's typically a sign
that you are not supporting yourself now
that you know the six blocks to
abundance I want to give you my methods
for clearing those blocks so that you
can allow abundance to flow to you it's
called the universal abundance method
the first step of the universal
abundance method is to protect your
desires so you can stay in alignment so
if you have a really important desire
something that you care about something
that you want to manifest into your life
it's extremely valuable not to talk
about it with anyone who might resist it
step two is to focus on giving rather
than getting
more we are in that service mentality
more positively the universe responds to
us puts you into an abundance mentality
quickly because the more you give the
more you will receive and step three is
to want more for others
it is an opportunity for us to see that
we all can succeed we all can have
abundance in our life and the second you
start to intend for others to have more
of what you want for yourself you start
to feel good you start to feel like
you're contributing you start to feel
like you're connecting and you're no
longer comparing or jealous and you're
no longer separating yourself from
others redirect your focus from what can
I get to how do I feel and really allow
that feeling of abundance to propel you
forward and create momentum and allow
the universe to bring to you all that
you desire what you believe about
yourself is the only thing that matters
at the end of the day no matter how much
outside affirmations you get or other
people telling you that you're amazing
if you don't believe in your heart that
you are amazing it won't none of that
will last like you've ever gone to an
event or you ever made a video or
created something or you're hanging out
with a friend and they tell you how
amazing you are and that feels good
right like the external affirmations and
validation feels great but then it fades
but that stuff doesn't last you don't
have somebody being a cheerleader for
you every day showing up in your bedroom
saying hooray go do this you're amazing
right we don't have that you have to be
that for yourself
if you're constantly only getting your
value as a human being from other people
when they tell you that you're amazing
you're never gonna love your life you're
never gonna love yourself
it has to come from you has to come from
you telling yourself and you believe in
that you are amazing
okay so that's that's a lot of words how
do you actually go off and do it
like for me it's this is why I believe
that lack of belief is the world's
number one problem
you know I can go and meet somebody and
fill them full of belief for a moment
but if they still don't believe in
themselves and they're going home back
to a life that they they had before
because they don't believe in themselves
enough
and so you have to design habits and
routines in systems and schedules to
slowly shift your belief in yourself
forward
every single day
and a good chunk of that is what you say
about yourself
when you look at yourself in the mirror
what do you say when you think about
yourself what do you say a lot of a lot
of the stuff that we say about ourselves
we wouldn't we wouldn't say to our
worst enemies it's rough
I actually think it's great to be your
own worst critic
I think it's great I think honestly I
think for a lot of people we're not hard
enough on ourselves let me let me stick
with me for a minute we're not hard
enough on ourselves because in order to
get to where you want to go you actually
need to push yourself more the problem
is why we can't do it is
we don't love ourselves enough we're not
our biggest cheerleader enough you have
to balance those two things we're very
hard on ourselves but because there's no
self-love we're not cheering ourselves
on enough we're not our biggest
cheerleader
you can't handle it most people are
already at the breaking point you know
like sitting here in a parking lot these
you know those I guess it's kind of
blurry you can't really see them but
people hate their lives
they're barely hanging on most people
are barely hanging on
barely hanging on to what we're doing we
we can post all these great things on
Instagram or wherever and make it look
like we're enjoying our life but most
people are barely hanging on the people
who are judging you for your life and
telling you that you suck hate their own
lives they are barely hanging on so how
do we get through it well yes we can be
hard on ourselves but we need to balance
that with more self-love
you have to remind yourself of why
you're great what you're proud of what
you're grateful for
and it has to be consistent otherwise
you'll never get to where you want to go
and when you love yourself more that
actually allows you to be harder on
yourself
when you love yourself when you actually
feel it you can push yourself harder
you can you can be more
um
demanding of yourself
because it's not going to push you over
the edge because you're not tying your
self-worth
to you accomplishing that thing and when
you don't accomplish it you feel like a
loser
starting from a place of I'm amazing
that allows you to be way harder on
yourself when I go to events
a YouTube event for example if I'm
talking about anything entrepreneurship
or YouTube related
I'm going in thinking
I'm Kick-Ass
and because I feel that I don't need to
say that
like a lot of times we feel like we need
to say that because it's it's masculine
and insecurity right it's like those
people who uh we've seen those memes
where
when people make a little bit of money
they've got all these chains and
everything but then the people who are
Ultra rich
who have all the money
you look even Jay-Z like early Jay-Z you
know he's got all this change and
everything now he's like doesn't care
you know just walking on a T-shirt and
some jeans
because he doesn't need to front
because it's just so self-confident now
that it doesn't matter now it's actually
expression instead of masculine
insecurity most of us are just masking
insecurities instead of actually being
self-confident
and so when I'm going to an event if I'm
talking about YouTube I'm walking in
feeling amazing
and I don't need to
I don't need to walk her out and say hey
look at me
and it's actually the opposite I can go
up and say hey where do I suck it's my
favorite question to ask why do I suck
where do I suck can you point it out if
I can find one person to tell me where I
suck at something how my videos suck my
thumbnails suck do I don't believe that
they suck
right I think they're amazing
but because I think they're so amazing
it allows me to go a lot harder on
myself
and so people will give their honest
opinion and say hey here's how I think
it could be better
and so I think we need to do that more
in our lives we need to cheer ourselves
up more we need to cheer ourselves on
more so how do we do it let me let me
share some practical tips for you to
execute
number one
music in the morning
every morning one of the most important
things that I do is I put music on and
it's music that makes me move makes me
dance makes me there's some songs that
came on you would have to you would have
to move
right doesn't mean that you're up and
like dancing through the whole house
going crazy in your underwear first
thing in the morning but something that
even if it's just making your head Bob
there are songs that if they came on
would make your head Bob and you'd
probably be singing maybe not out loud
but singing under your breath I'm gonna
tune along
and be intentional with the lyrics
because if we're singing Out lyrics that
are negative
that has a lasting impact but if you're
singing Out lyrics that are positive
that also has a lasting impact
so be intentional with music that you
put on Every Day first start your day
with music it's the fastest way to
change your state to go from feeling low
and tired and just what what day is it
what am I doing I wake up every day like
what day is it what am I doing today yes
but I demand excellence and that that
starts with music because I don't have I
don't want to spend a lot of time trying
to get into the right state of mind I
can command it whenever I want just by
putting on the right song so be in
tension with your music and the lyrics
being positive two
connect to the work that you're doing
and how meaningful it is
so the next thing I'll do is I'll take
the dogs out and then I'll go for what I
call a believe walk and this is probably
the most important part of my morning
routine is I go for a believe walk and
it's a minimum of 20 minutes and it's a
maximum of an hour
and I'll go for a walk by myself with 20
pounds on my back I'll go rucking a walk
to Tim Hortons usually get a coffee you
know this costs two bucks two something
so I only had you know what's the what's
the best money I spend every year well
it's the 700 bucks
of going on my believe walk and getting
a coffee every morning and I'm thinking
about what's my intention for the day
and I'm thinking about what I want to
accomplish today and the lives that I
want to serve and the people I want to
help and and what I'm about to do today
and
it's a mini celebration
where most of the time we wake up like
an accident right you wake up you're
probably late for something you
immediately look at your phone what's on
your phone it's other people's demands
for your time other people's emergencies
of what they think you should do with
your schedule today right that's what's
in your phone all the DMS and the emails
and the texts and the missed calls and
all it's all other people's agenda for
your time that that is not an
intentional life we wake up like an
accident and start falling into what
other people want us to do today that's
not what you need to do and you need to
protect your time
so the morning
having to believe walk for me if you
want to go on your own whether it's 20
minutes or an hour that's really just a
feel thing too I don't book anything
until 10 30 at the earliest in my
calendar most of my meetings would be 11
first meeting would be 11 movement
makers and brand lytics I'll start at 10
30. uh and before that there's nothing
officially planned or scheduled so that
it gives my morning free to do whatever
I want to do and so if I want to go for
a hour-long believe walk instead of 20
minutes I can do that because I'm
thinking because I'm brainstorming
because I'm I'm
going through an idea I treat that as
walking meditation
um if you like to meditate meditate I
mean it's the same thing I just find
meditation doesn't really help me that
much I like something a little more
active so I go I believe walks
do those two things
put on a playlist put on music every
morning
with lyrics that inspire you
and then go for a believe walk
20 minutes
to think about what you want to do today
what you want to accomplish how you want
to spend your time where you want to be
intentional
so you can start living the life that
you want to live
because the only thing that matters how
you feel about yourself
are you proud of you today
are you happy with what you've done
today
are you
joyful in how you showed up for you
today and yes we ultimately want to
serve and help others
but the only thing that matters
is how you feel about yourself
so we can stop relying on external
validation and somebody else's words of
affirmation for us to
feel Worthy
and flip it to say I am worthy I am
amazing
I can do great things
and when you can shift into that energy
you will do great things
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome now it's
time to watch the most eye-opening 60
Minutes of your life check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there here's the hard truth about
getting great it takes time and
dedication it takes a willingness to
accept that you're not yet good enough
it takes the ability to stare at the
places